il dit une femme qui ne vous embrasse
pas vraiment ne vous aime pas évidemment
qui dit le contraire
Philippe comment ça va bien vous publiez
chez Gallimard une vie divine un roman
qui commence par l'histoire d'amour
entre un professeur de philosophie
vieillissant et une jeune et belle et
cervelet dénommée Ludi vendeuse dans un
magasin de prêt-à-porter dans le 8e
arrondissement alors entre l'intello et
la bimbo c'est la passion une passion
libre agrémentée d'amment et maîtresse
d'un couple moderne comme on dit alors
le philosophe lui il a employé au
ministère il travaille sur Nietzsche sa
vie son œuvre et petit à petit Nietzsche
devient le personnage central du livre
et à la sortie on a un roman total qui
mélange fiction et ses citations
biographies et qui dit finalement à quel
point la pensée de Nietzsche est
toujours d'actualité et combien elle a
été dévoyé c'est vrai que quand on pense
à Nietzsche on pense tout de suite à
nazi sur rhum Wagner et quand on lit
votre bouquin on s'aperçoit qu'en fait
le pauvre homme il était plutôt
chapelinaise que disons le pauvre homme
le génial pourquoi tu l'étais à ce point
censurer oblitérer interprété falsifier
par sa par sa mère alors je suis par sa
sœur surtout qu'est-ce qui s'est emparé
de l'Allemagne à un certain moment alors
que voilà l'esprit le plus libre qui est
existé en allemand et en Allemagne
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là
pourquoi ton fait de sonner ce cet
épouvantail à cause du sérum alors le
problème c'était de tout simplement de
regarder un peu les choses qu'il a écrit
sa vie j'ai un narrateur là qui vit
d'une certaine façon et qui s'intéresse
aux choses fondamentaliste de monde
comment on pourrait sortir de du 20e
siècle de ces désastre alors il tombe
sur Nietzsche il trouve ça très frais
très très électrique très très actuel
très très caustique très au-delà des
lois très par-delà le bien et le mal
puisque c'est ça votre sur la fin
toujours le bien le bas très au-delà de
la morale quelle horreur la moralité la
morale qu'est-ce qui infeste à ce point
la vie humaine depuis 2000 ans sinon la
moralité la morale le bien le mal la
religion etc qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on
pourrait peut-être sortir de ce
cauchemar
et alors il a écrit les livres que
excusez-moi que j'ai lu et puis il y a
des bibliothèques sur lui et puis on
s'aperçoit que personne a fait attention
à sa vie à sa vie concrète comment il a
vécu qu'est-ce que c'était vraiment j'ai
lu ça correspondant c'est ça c'est
absolument extraordinaire ça c'est le
pitch Julie voilà et puis après
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire il faut lire
le bouquin c'est en ça qu'il est très
difficile oui c'est vrai malheureusement
il faut le dire très difficile je suis
désolé c'est vrai qu'il est très
difficile de parler littérature à la
télévision alors mais non mais non on
peut noter des phrases moi j'ai noté
dans votre bouquin un certain nombre de
choses que je trouve très bien par
exemple une phrase j'aime bien c'est les
femmes n'aiment ni les hommes ni les
femmes mais les bébés oui mais c'est
vrai mais je crois j'aime bien ces
phrases comme ça
et c'est vrai les femmes aiment les
bébés bien sûr la preuve en
assisement
il se fait aimer comme bébé et alors
quand je suis un bébé elle-même tu
comprends les trucs
qui est une blonde et puis alors il y a
Nelly la brune alors que sa maîtresse
parce que là on retrouve libertin de
maîtresse évidemment
ennemi des moralistes et alors ce qui
est drôle c'est qu'il la baise
avec le mot est drôle
elle se met sur le canapé pour lui
montrer qu'elle a pas de culotte et il
la baise pendant qu'elle lit la Critique
de la raison pure voilà c'est magnifique
par exemple merci
je crois qu'en effet il y a la voiture
alors solaire
s'agit pas de mettre la Philosophie dans
le boudoir mais le bordel dans la
philosophie voilà c'est tout lui
réaction
le bordel dans la philosophie ça peut
donner quelque chose à jouir mais le
contraire non une fois
il est également question de Houellebecq
bien que vous ne le citiez pas et vous
dites de lui Daniel donc c'est le nom de
son personnage dans dans son dernier
bouquin et le type même du ni liste
d'aujourd'hui pornographe et
sentimentale et je crois que c'est
exactement ça
égoïste romantique et et pornographe et
sentimentale cette définit très bien
l'homme d'aujourd'hui je trouve et oui
c'est à dire quelqu'un de profondément
déprimé qui vit dans une sorte de
désespérance vous parler de ces Daniel
donc on comprend être Houellebecq vous
dites mauvaises enfance corp peut
désirable intense masturbation puis
découvert tardive de jeunes partenaires
attirés par sa célébrité et son argent
et là il prend conscience de son
vieillissement
est un écrivain important de notre
époque parce qu'il décrit exactement la
misère sexuelle de notre époque à
laquelle il faut quand même observer
qu'elle est niée
c'était pas mieux il y a 30 ans c'était
pire
pire pire non sans quoi
si
importants
je parle sans le citer qui s'appelle
Michel on est d'accord
c'est pas la peine de faire comme s'il
n'existait pas il existe mais même si il
a pas pris
de façon très très très précise et
pertinent la misère sexuelle dans
laquelle se trouve le monde contemporain
si vous voulez faire semblant d'être en
dehors de la misère sexuelle il faut
venir nous le prouver avec vos résultats
l'écrire et le publier il faut que
chacun parle de sa vie privée il faut
que chacun
ose dire que la façon dont il vit est-ce
que ça va est-ce que ça ne va pas est-ce
que vous frimez est-ce que vous inventez
est-ce que vous racontez n'importe quoi
il faut être précis dans ces choses et
c'est là-dessus que par exemple on
retrouve en effet la philosophie de
Nietzsche est-ce que vous voulez vivre
oui comme vous vivez oui ou non ou
est-ce que ça vous paraît barbant
assomant vous préféreriez en finir vous
êtes frustrés déprimé mélancoliques et
c'est ça en effet qui est dans le monde
que nous vivons un monde merveilleux ou
le faux bonheur rutile de partout et où
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça
qu'on devrait remarquer là ça part de
l'enquête très précise tout de même
c'est-à-dire en effet le baiser profond
le french kiss comme disent les autres
c'est là et après tout le reste s'ensuit
mais s'il y a pas cette espèce de de de
baiser au souffle profond non mais c'est
très important
il dit une femme qui ne vous embrasse
pas vraiment ne vous aime pas évidemment
qui dit le contraire personne je suis
d'accord
les filles
les filles sont d'accord elles sont
d'accord il faut savoir d'accord
si on a envie d'embrasser voilà ne
zappez pas il y aura d'autres phrases
restez avec nous et maintenant on va
faire l'interview des grands l'interview
la plus difficile de cette émission elle
s'appelle
upside down
qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter de
pire en ce moment écoutez à part la mort
des gens que j'aime et ou bien le fait
que je sois atteinte brusquement d'une
crise cardiaque je crois que ce qui
serait le pire c'est la disparition
brutale magique terrible de tous mes
livres dans toutes les librairies à
l'heure actuelle oui
le défaut que j'aimerais avoir je sais
pas peut-être peut-être la curiosité
poussée très loin parce que je je
m'encoure l'indiscation je ne l'ai pas
pour y être animateur de télévision par
exemple peut-être il faudrait que je me
force quelle est la qualité que vous
regrettez d'avoir je crois que ce quand
même
oh oui la courtoisie
18e c'est la politesse
la courtoisie vraiment
qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait envie
d'être trompé par une femme alors soit
qu'elle je découvre qu'elle préfère des
imbéciles et pourquoi pas ou alors
qu'elle lit en cachette des romans
d'Anna Gavalda
en quoi aimeriez-vous être beaucoup plus
mauvais
j'aimerais être plus mauvais en
méchanceté je n'arrive je n'y arrive pas
non non je n'y arrive pas vraiment
j'aimerais être plus méchant c'est la
même chose que pour courtoisie et
franchement là je quels sont quels sont
les défauts que doit avoir une femme
pour vous séduire là c'est dans le livre
c'est une femme est séduisante à partir
du moment où je sens qu'elle est une
bonne menteuse si elle est une bonne
menteuse parce que d'habitude ben oui si
elle ment bien détendu quand même c'est
pour lui l'intérieur de cette dame
est-ce qu'elle ment bien quelle est
l'insulte qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir on s'est un vieil article
c'était au merveilleux d'ailleurs rien
de nouveau sous le soleil
qui vous énerve le plus quand on dit que
je suis brillant intelligent cultivée
etc on vous le fera plus
quel est le talent que vous n'aimeriez
pas avoir
j'aimerais pas avoir le le don de
galvaniser des foules
pour l'instant tout va bien
par qui aimeriez-vous être détesté
et bien je crois que je suis et je
depuis l'au-delà franchement c'est par
François Mitterrand voilà je joue ok je
l'aime pas du tout ça pas du tout
donc pas du tout
l'ami que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir
Ben Laden allez ouais bon vous
connaissez pas en même temps
quel est le best-seller que vous
n'auriez pas aimé écrire alors j'aurais
bien aimé toucher l'argent de DaVinci
code mais pas le pas l'écrire comment
faire voilà je peux pas
un pseudo joyau
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu